[Music]  hey guys welcome back top the record  where we talk about whatever we want and  thank you so much for supporting us on  patreon Thank You Petri all we're gonna  talk about exclusive [ __ ] and we get to  say whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass  [ __ ] deep don't [ __ ] we want whether  it's necessary or not  exactly this morning  Bart's phone got stolen by who somebody  who knows you trying to get either your  dick tix or geo but picture of whatever  typical don't know if he stole my phone  or not but it's worth a try Asik hey did  you find an iPhone and he was like  speaking of things just moved up yes  this is my first week oh boy only the  patreon people can watch this so if  you're on YouTube you know what the real  juice is about to come out  [Music]